subject matter today
and i hope you uh enjoy it
okay
[Music]
right you very much
at the minutes these are on page three
i'll go through each page individually
three
four
thank you
oh sorry can we please vote on the
minister
all those in favor
against
extensions
a declaration of interest members with
interest to declare should refer to the
gender item and describe the nature of
their interest
when the item is being considered
agreement between uh parts one and two
we have a proposal
thank you
[Music]
and
second
[Music]
urgent matters are brought forward um i
have no urgent matters today
right so now we go straight into
our first main item
which is
[Music]
full view
amendments to best practice
okay
sorry stacy will introduce
so this is the report that's now been
published
by the government a little late because
obviously they had the pandemic to deal
with and it was published in november
2021
um
and it was to review the standards of
public life the standards regime which
as a whole hasn't been reviewed for 15
years
and obviously there's quite a
substantial report there so i won't um
go through all of it but i will just
summarize some some points for the
committee
um effectively um
they are in agreement that their seven
principles seven nolan principles are
still good
um which is good from our perspective
because that is what our code of conduct
is is based upon
um they have made
one slight recommendation
that the principle of good leadership
should be amended slightly
to state that it's important that
individuals are treated with respect
but they're saying overall the standards
regime has not been functioning
as well as it should be
but i think predominantly
that's really
not necessarily the regime as it's been
implemented but i think the sanctions
that can be imposed under the regime are
quite um
weak if i'm honest
and the government have been looking
into this as well
but effectively the summary of the
report is that the committee has
recommended that the government
legislate in respective standards um in
respect of um
[Music]
different public sorry different public
leaders
and
recommended that an obligation is
created by the government to produce a
code of conduct that is set down in
legislation
um and which outlines the guiding
principles and purposes of the code of
conduct again based on the seven million
principles
[Music]
well i think it's worth noting
that
i think it's social media television
information
it's so free to study today
that there's 34 recommendations for
alterations and strengthening
um
[Music]
unfortunately that's going to be a lot
of work and i suspect it's the same
civil servant it'll have to move on to
work on ourselves
anybody else have any comments or
questions
just for the chair that's seriously is
there any plans for any more training
for us
on you know
these new regulations things like that
are we in the future we're going to have
more training and perhaps we should all
be um
sort of made aware or reminded of the
seven principles as well because
sometimes while you
you lose
what my mind means
i think
as a committee we shouldn't be
you know we should be up there
um
as the established committee
we should do some
principles we would like to name
you know i think perhaps we should have
um as a committee
have some sort of paperwork or something
like that given to us
so that we can keep it and so that we
can remind ourselves
thank you
so we did just have training
in november standards training it was
offered by um beth
and
if there was a consensus and members
wanted
more training or
i could arrange for beth to come back in
and it was done on the new code as well
um
but obviously it does cost us as an
authority so
if there was enough members wanting that
i i'm quite happy to arrange that back
and if that says
can i just ask tom
i believe that making a presentation
like that feels really cool do we still
have that yes
it might be
[Music]
and anybody else that would like to
see that recording and it is available
yes
[Music]
right so now we move on to
[Music]
and this is the one that's been um
issued um the model code opponents
commissioned by the local government
association
um i have also appended um torridge's
current code of conduct
members which is attached at page one
two five also
um
in comparing the bow that that they're
not dissimilar to one another and i
couldn't immediately see anything that
jumped out
that is in the model code that isn't
already contained within um
torridge's code of um
conduct as it stands and so at this
stage i probably would recommend to
members that we we leave our current
creative product as it is um because
there's really very little difference
between between them
[Music]
unless members of the country you
i just have a question please check at
least the treatment that we have
um i don't see the difference i'd
honestly between elected members and
non-elected members like myself
regarding dba checks and why they're not
subject to that as well and there's
probably a reason maybe because we don't
have close contact with the community as
members do um
[Music]
and i don't know a reason myself i'm
just wondering if it's because
you don't have the authority to you
could request it
i think
it's saying up to election members and
so we ask that they do have dps checks
undertaken but we can't make it
mandatory
um
but the same with independence i i don't
see any difficulty if you wanted to to
have that dbs check as well um and what
we do now within torrent as we noted on
our website if that members had a dps
check or or not but it's not mandatory
within the legislation from foreign
thank you thank you
that's reported yeah just
this is perfect at that point john just
sent police email and i did bring up the
vote council more concerned about dbs
checks actually okay on a very serious
matter
that to me is escalated
because recently i don't know whether
people are aware of his next counselor
there was convicted very serious defense
a naval authority
i think it would be wise to contact the
neighborhood authority because they were
going to take it back to their countries
and see if it could be strengthened that
were made now debris
because this is serious issues
is
[Music]
i'm not sure if it's on
on if if you go on the website and click
on each country
um
it's really important actually it does
not what it says is gps completed or an
empty thing i did mention this i think
it should say not achieve now being
serious
this is for every vulnerable people that
we might have aspiring for we are
looking into that right so
um
i i mean i look through and i can see
very little difference between
the model and our own uh given that
all the toys are gonna be thrown up in
the in the air hopefully shortly
um i don't use work playing with it at
the moment
[Music]
extensions
he's on his way
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh at the moment
we have
nothing sitting on it
so
the members have any
ideas
any items they would like
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh right okay so now we need to go
right so
excluded from the remainder of the
meeting because of the likely disclosure
exact information as defined
[Music]
thank you